two months after protests erupted
opponents of ukrainian president
yanukovych refused to give up they
demand urgent constitutional reform and
an end to the brutal repression they've
suffered the eu has strongly condemned
the violence there's still great concern
about the situation
on the ground and great concern to see
that those who have committed violence
are brought to justice late january mep
delegation traveled to kiev to assess
the situation and hold talks with the
government and the pro-european
opposition
back in strasbourg they've urged
president yanikovic to stop the arrests
and torture of the opposition
i think it is unbelievable and
unacceptable that in
europe today we have still in one
country
death squads
torture
people
brought into the woods killed or left
wounded behind
so this has to stop absolutely
rebellions have erupted throughout the
country despite the resignation of prime
minister mikula azeroth last week
brutality by the anti-protest police the
berkut has radicalised the opposition
meps want to put pressure on the current
regime they've called for urgent action
from the eu and member states we have to
prepare a number of target sanctions
against the regime and against
individual members of the regime
i think personally on treatings banning
them from traveling to europe
restricting their visas
and also most important freezing their
assets
it's unlikely that these measures will
be enough ukraine has agreed to a 15
billion dollar trade deal on bonds with
russia and a 30 discount on gas
aid from the west cannot match russia's
proposal
meps are calling on the eu the u.s and
imf and the world bank to produce a
long-term financial aid package for the
country